there's a specific kind of body I want
okay okay
what are the comps I want to look like
um Mark
1976 Jet Li oh from the one oh no yes so
skinny but muscle skinny why are you
doing that with your mouth it's just
that's the hardest body you could pick
why are you doing that's so hydrated and
let me tell you something about that
mouth you just did right
exactly what I don't want in my life
right is doubters okay okay all right so
let's start over
let's do it again okay do it again so I
want to look like
um
1985. that's what I wanna
do the pose to the pose easy show us the
pose
easy
attainable look at
that why did you laugh like that that's
mocking me you don't think I can do that
I think I think you I believe in you
are you stuttering what the [__] what's
going on here what the [__] is going on
here I think you could do anything well
I think you can get like the muscles
it's just that like your proportions are
a little strange yeah like your arms are
very short so yeah but that's going to
be good for bench press you're right
you're right you're gonna be able to
bench so much thank you yeah what else
is going to be good
your height you're gonna be so small and
like whoa
I feel you just made fun of him
your height you are short no one likes
you
and then you're going to be so small
what does it even mean I want to be
petite and like eye contact Megan has a
point because thank you um I do find you
the most attractive when you uh have
meat on your body yeah but the meat that
you have we could turn that into muscle
and right right
so when you poop you can poop like two
pounds US ladies I worked really hard
and lost one pound a week of like pure
discipline
one week I tried running every day I
gained four pounds of inflammation and
just fixed it and I was like I cannot
win get on testosterone you're gonna be
so it's gonna be like one month oh
shredded I wanna do steroids start with
trt everyone does it what's your team
let's do it testosterone you inject it
in your ass you have it maybe
you're over 30. eligible that was a
low-key guy
I want to be high tooth I've always
wanted to be High kid like the problem
is you're already really horny so you
might you might have a triple t Okay I
want to go high you're gonna be jerking
off a lot yeah yeah I have an issue yeah
yeah do it come on let me ask you about
that what are the um negative side
effects of a trt I don't have to think
about it no no no no I don't watch
shrunken balls my balls are already
shrunken you could take something else
that'll counteract that you just add on
to it are your balls Sean came back no
you just you take something else what
would you take HCG so you take two
things
or you can't you can't you don't want to
do that you just yeah you take that
because then it signals it's a whole
thing is it bad for blood pressure I
have high blood pressure so if I take
tntic
Movie Network oh yeah star a big big
suit that'd be a good movie a guy that
thinks he's taking steroids yeah it
explodes at the end of the movie I like
that it's not bad yeah it's the same
story I was like a year and a half sober
or a little over a year sober this is
recent and I was like still depressed
still down like didn't feel good and I
was like I'm doing everything right I'm
working out all the time taking care of
myself and I was still not
good and I go to this this doctor do a
blood test and he goes this is what's
happening you're a little low you're low
T you're low T man Low T now I feel like
my mood feels better
I I can work out more you get the TNT
from the Mexico or from America that's
America I don't know where they go I
don't know where they go I know but I
know a lot of people that go down
American Dynamite sweetie you don't want
yeah I want Mexican in my bottle but
it's a little it's a super low dose yeah
Bert just started too Bert Kreischer
still looks like I can't I don't want to
explain it but like we just started the
thing without the rocky pictures he
needs more stuff baby yeah that doesn't
look good I don't want that
yeah yeah I want to look different but
if you want to this yeah you want to
look like that lips might need a little
extra help a little extra help I'll do
it I just don't want to get a stroke
nah the doctor will help you okay but
the vaping is no good my friend The
Vaping is no good we're going uh what
happened I wanted to show you this blood
clot that came out of my nose yeah
wait wait can you texted me did you send
it to me I'll send it to Gilbert and you
put on the big screen bloody booger or
straight from me no so I had a nosebleed
I'll have nosebleeds but this lasted 40
minutes and I had like you know you get
the blood clot at the end and then it
ends yeah I had six of them and the last
one that came out of me
was the size of my hand and I took my
picture that's dangerous I was like can
I call somebody you plan oops you've
never had it your nose like cauterized
or anything no this is bad like I've had
many nosebleeds and I've never seen
anything like this in my life were you
worried I weighed him down he was in the
backyard I was like go inside I think
I'm dying
yes no good what's the [__] is that it
oh my God oh my God oh my God it has a
face
so like she's been under some uh High
Stress and Anxiety recently yeah he
thinks it's a stress demon I came out it
was a demon that left her brain
immediately feel relief after the nose
he's like oh my God
that's a child of Earth holy [__] it's
so dark
and the top was it the top right that
faces what that no no I see the version
memory
download that one I just sent yeah wow
that's crazy zoom in you see the nose
Justin point to the nose yeah
if you turn it this way I see the face
[Applause]
look zoom in zoom in Zoom yeah point at
it I'm trained yeah right there oh
oh my God I see it yeah it's like a bear
I see a bear
like a little bit anyway it looks like
Ryan's face oh that's insane that's my
face yeah
is it the little lips like yeah if that
happened to me I would go
oh my God honestly you got to go to the
hospital
you're okay I don't think so I've never
seen that before in my life
nosebleeds could happen with hormone
hormonal changes when you're pregnant I
was like okay but with that much like
tissue coming out like I've never bled
like in a period without much tissue the
one before that the clot I just like
blew it out and it went straight up my
face
you're not concerned of course why have
you guys taken your you gotta take your
sister to the [__] doctor dude she's
also tough I go you're good you're fine
well Massachusetts yeah yeah I know I
understand that but it could be
something serious okay well you're the
nurse go ahead I that that's concerning
okay thank you I'll text it to my doctor
right now yeah yeah now I know I see I
told her I said text your doctor you
said I know everyone's like what'd you
say I was like I didn't know she never
texted her I'm gonna do her now it's
just the amount it was a lot yeah but
especially if you said there's six of
them that came yeah there because I was
like oh I got the blood clot I'm good
and then I just kept Raining Blood and
then more blood clots and I was like God
it just won't slow down can I ask you
guys something because of the workout
like a side note yeah is there I want to
buy a machine
yeah what kind there's what you're
telling me there's machines you could
put like no no no no no no no like not
like the shake wake
I don't do a [__]
I want to buy I want to buy like workout
gear like a bench in a bar like
something where I can at night go do
this I want to do this I don't know what
they're called so I want to do this like
a Bowflex
[Laughter]
right I want to do this one right do you
remember seeing Chuck Norris on that
Bowflex I was like yeah I'm gonna be
Chuck Norris yeah get this Bowflex
biggest scam of all time I think so you
like Chuck Norris I just I just looked
at his son he has a son he has several
Sons oh wow his son's a stunt Corey
seemed like the man and he's the nicest
guy that his son I mean it kind of looks
like Chuck anyway I don't know I just
said that that's cool but yeah you just
need a I mean yeah what let me where do
you get this from your eyes are close
together because they don't have I don't
know he has what I have it's I like it I
love that I call it fashionably
cross-eyed no I am I am actually I'm
actually Crossing
what you look like you got so conscious
as a fool no no because I I am you're
beautiful